javascript is the go-to language for
developers looking to build versatile
and performant web applications
and javascript developers are some of
the most sought after hires at startup
and enterprise companies alike
that's why udacity has partnered with
industry experts to bring you the skills
you need to build
and deploy javascript applications from
end to end
in the full stack javascript developer
nanodegree program
you will take your development skills to
the next level and learn how to deliver
exceptional user experiences with a
modern architecture and technology stack
the program will cover back-end
development with node.js
api development with postgresql and
express
students will also learn how to deploy
applications to a production environment
with automated pipelines
over the course of the program you'll
demonstrate your ability to implement
these essential javascript skills in
four distinct projects
modeled after real business cases from
front end to back end
develop the practical experience you
need to create modern applications that
will support your company's goals
and keep your customers engaged enroll
in udacity's full stack javascript
developer nanodegree program today